ron perlman
he's the actor who played hellboy and
has been in some other things ron
perlman has been going on some unhinged
twitter rants in recent days
ron perlman
just
gave a rant toward florida governor ron
desantis reacting to
the don't say gay bill
good morning governor desantis
around here
um
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't
say you nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about
it then run for office
you piece of [ __ ]
yeah read about it read about it you
gotta read you're not doing your reading
that's why you passed a bill
that i was told by the media is called
the don't say gay bill
even though i didn't read it
and i don't realize it doesn't say don't
say anything at all
yes this guy no one has ever accused ron
perlman of being the brightest spelled
in the pack but this guy
is
yelling at ron desantis for something
that he's never said
he's he's yelling about a bill
because of something the bill does not
say then he gets really hot under the
collar about it
i i don't think
that ron perlman is an outlier
yes he's a hollywood guy yes he's a
little eccentric
i think that's what most
liberals who oppose the don't say gay
bill
i think that's what they're reacting
about i think they're reacting in
basically exactly the same way as ron
perlman they are tilting at windmills
they're fighting against something
they're knocking down straw men they're
fighting against something
that is not
real perlman just came out he sent out
another
angry
twitter video at senator tom cotton for
his questioning of the supreme court
judge the the nominee katanji jackson
tom cotton
that can't really be your name can it
was it
product
your unpaid employees pick for you
for profit
you [ __ ] white slaver
piece of [ __ ]
that line of questioning you pulled
on that incredibly beautiful woman
yesterday
your staff is probably cowering
as you read those statistics
that they under duress put together for
you unless they're a bunch of white
slavers too
which is probably the case
who else would work for you you piece of
[ __ ]
play back your line of questioning
and tell me that wasn't the most racist
thing i've seen since jefferson
[ __ ]
davis
someone clearly received his biden crack
pipe delivery before the rest of us did
i keep waiting i keep checking my
mailbox where is my biden crack pipe and
there ron pearlman got his and probably
a few other people's before that's the
only way that i can explain this except
except for this
what's his argument his argument here is
republicans
who criticize katanji jackson the most
radical supreme court nominee ever in
the history of the country
they are racist
that's all he's saying he's got colorful
language and he's saying it in kind of a
stupid way but that's the point that's
the thesis republicans
if they oppose this nominee are racist
that's what every liberal believes
pretty much maybe that's a little unfair
that's what every
prominent liberal
says
that's what the leading democrats say
that's what the leading television
commentators say that's what the leading
blue checkmark liberals are saying
that's what they're almost all saying
republicans are opposing this woman
because she's black because they're
racist even beyond this woman
republicans are racist
that's why they do what they do is
because they hate black people
that republicans
who who support the florida education
bill they hate free speech they're
opposing the first that's
he he sounds like a dummy because we can
hear him and we can see him
but he's not saying anything different
than any of the prominent liberals on
either of those issues how terrifying is
that we're living in a nation
half full of ron parolemans
right now go to rockauto.com and write
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that i sent you
rockauto.com is going to save you money
it's going to save you time it's going
to help you to
improve your car improve your truck to
do the things that you've got to do to
get around to live your life and you're
not going to have to stand and wait at
the brick and mortar store where you
drive you wait in line you get peppered
with a thousand questions they don't
have the part because there's just too
many parts to stock these days then you
got to go back you got to wait two weeks
don't do it rockauto.com
same reliably low prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers but you could save 20
30 50
on the parts that you need the website's
so easy to navigate even i can do it
they're a great family company serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
great supporters of this show which we
really appreciate head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and then
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s and their
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you
did you like that clip hold on
whether you did or you didn't i don't
really care subscribe anyway ring that
bell get the notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]